hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 18 of my payto playay flipping
series we're going to go from zero to
100 Mil using the grand exchange
only today we're starting at about 26
mil I honestly have no idea what the
exact cashtag is um somewhere around 26
and a half mil I
believe and yeah we're going to see
where we can go from here today hoping
to hit 30 mil pretty soon uh we have
eight days of membership left uh so
we'll have to renew that in a couple
days and yeah let's get started okay so
we might actually try the Elder chaos
top uh we're just going to check the
margin here quickly buying it for 750
that's a nice even number and we're
selling it for 650k 100k on an item like
this is pretty decent um and it does
actually trade more than the darkness
set margin isn't as good but
unfortunately um the margin on the
darkness set has reduced a little bit so
we'll go ahead and buy 20 of these for
651k
instead H we'll check it again anyway
we're going to check the hood of dark Co
my God we put it in for 2.9 mil got to
stop doing that uh so we bought it for
248k and we're going to sell it for
1994 that's actually still pretty decent
we'll do the hood of Darkness um one
more time and eventually I'm sure it's
going to be complete trash but for now
it's decent and we'll do another 20 of
these okay actually probably going to
check the rest of the darkness items
while we're at it because that has a
pretty good margin on it and oh my God
we did it again okay we're good jeez so
we bought for 300
4K and we can sell up for 254 that's
still pretty decent that's a 50k margin
still really good just just worse so it
doesn't feel as desirable but it's still
a really good item so we'll do 20 of
these and we'll come back when some of
the stuff has sold okay we are back um
we made a good amount of money on one of
the items the other ones we kind of
broke even on uh SL are kind of still in
the process of selling um so the hood of
Darkness we only got one of rendering
our profit pretty much nothing because
we checked the margin cancel s out we
pretty much made nothing but we didn't
lose any uh which is
nice um the boots of Darkness are still
in the process of selling so we're not
going to do that now uh zamak Set uh we
made about 90k on now I can't remember
if we had bought more than one of these
at all but 90k is the margin we got on
it um but the chaos robe tops Elder
chaos tops sorry um we bought them all
for 6.5 mil and we sold them for
7.25 mil uh giv us about 740k profit
which is quite good actually and I think
only took about I lifted an overnight so
about 740k overnight is pretty decent
and yeah let's see what else we can do
so we kind of saw these anku gloves here
and we're literally just going to put in
a pretty random number here uh just kind
of roughly looking at the RS buddy price
put in for 6.8 mil it's very under what
it normally is but we'll see if it buys
randomly and yeah we'll get some more
consistent items though okay so next up
is the elder chaos Hood it's a decently
expensive item so we're going to check
it manually uh so we're going to put in
for like 1.5 mil to buy it in a minute
here and not really sure what type of
margin this has on it uh we're going to
buy it for 1.4 mil and let's see what we
can actually sell it for plop it in for
1 mil just in case it undersells
extremely h no we sold it uh has about
100K profit on it which is pretty decent
uh not as good as the other the Elder
chaos top um but I think we're still
going to do it uh because it is traded a
little bit more and might uh actually
keep that margin overnight so we'll go
put 10 in for 134 3K actually I think
I'm going to just buy five of these uh
at least then we'll have about 12 mil
left over we can buy a couple different
items instead of just like small amount
of one next up is going to be the ale of
the Gods now this is just a random
Master clue item I've seen kind of makes
you look drunk and walk around so it's
kind of cool I think people would
actually still want this it them uh
decently expensive though um so we're
going to check the margin manually we
bought it for 6.9 mil and let's see how
much we can sell it for see if we can
sell it for 6 mil or higher and
6,300 okay uh so that's a 600 GP 600k
profit mind you sorry um so I think
we're definitely going to do this we
kind of have to now CU we just lost 600k
jeez uh so we'll put the offer in for
one unfortunately that's all we can
afford
H I think we might reduce another item
to afford too actually uh but we'll come
back when um we've sold some of this
stuff we actually managed to scr enough
money for one more a of the Gods which
was nice because the first one cost us
so much money to check it but now we're
actually making quite a bit of money off
this item uh first we'll just start with
the other item the Elder chaos Hood uh
we got about 160k in profit so far we've
sold half of them uh hopefully the other
two will sell pretty soon but the a of
the Gods we are getting about 500 in 50k
profit on each flip uh we flipped three
of them uh mind you the first one was a
loss cuz we checked the margin but that
still leaves us with about a 1.1 mil
profit which is awesome that's a great
item definitely going to try this again
especially now that we found the margin
uh so yeah definitely going to do this
again so let's see what we have for a
cash tag and start flipping it more okay
so we're going to start off by dropping
down the boots of Darkness they've been
here for way too long it's been it's
been almost to a day I think or day and
a half kind of hard to remember now um
yeah we reduced them down to 290k that
still leaves us with a 40K profit so
still could be worse and so yeah we have
24 mil and we're going to put another
offering for the a of the Gods we can
afford not quite four we'll have to do
three again um but yeah hopefully we can
keep the same margin and we'll come back
when we've sold some of them so we are
back um we haven't sold everything oh we
have sold everything sorry but we
haven't bought uh all the AL of gods we
only flipped one
still for a very good margin uh but
we'll start with the other two items we
have for a while uh so the Elder chaos
Hood in total we got about 32k from it
uh which is pretty nice still um not
nearly as good as other item though uh
the boots I have no idea really between
300 and 400k in profit roughly it's been
a couple days so it's kind of hard to
remember but the AL of the Gods we just
straight up flip for
a 550k profit I guess uh so that's
really nice nice we still have an
offering for two more at about 6.5 mil
uh so the margin slimmed a little bit
but still really good so we're
definitely going to keep buying these
and yeah let's get started with the
flips okay so I think we're going start
off by readjusting the price for the a
the gods cuz I can see the actively
trade prices up to 7,100 K so we're
going to put an offer in for 6650 k for
two of them and probably find another
item uh besides that as well to go along
with it so I think we might do this
elder chaos Hood again
that the grand Exchange price is so off
um it's more like 1.3 mil we pretty much
bought for 12.91 K and we're going to
sell it
for
1202 so that's about a 90k margin not
too bad for the item and I think we're
going to do it cuz the RS buddy guide
showed it being a little bit higher than
that and we're getting a little lazy and
tired so I think we're just going to put
an offer in for like 10 of these go to
bed and see if we buy them all and see
if we can actually get that'll be about
a 1 mil profit which is still really
awesome so we'll come back when we've
sold this and we are back and my hunch
actually did pay off we got quite a bit
of money from the Elder chaos hoods
we'll start off with the AL the gods the
margin did Slim up quite a bit we got
150k on each one and two of those gives
us 300K in profit still not too shabby
but the Elder chaos hoods we got 296k on
each one five of those gives us about,
1500k in profit 1.5 mil which is great
um minus a little bit to check the
margin uh but still quite a nice margin
on that and I actually think this is
where we're going to call it for today I
know it's a bit of a short episode but
as the flips take longer to do as I do
higher value flips just the amount of
Clips gets reduced a little bit which in
turn makes it take a little longer to
come up with the episodes I'm going to
reduce the lengths a little bit uh so I
can actually still come up with them
consistantly but that aside we started
the episode about 26ish Mill probably
26.5 hard to know and we ended at about
31.3 mil so worst case scenario made
about 5 mil on profit which is awesome
still probably one of the highest we've
made and definitely the lowest amount of
flip so really good episode I hope you
guys enjoyed and I will see you guys in
episode 19
[Music]